♪ ♪ ♪
- Est-ce l'argent qui corrompt
ou au contraire, faut-il être
corrompu pour accumuler
des milliards?
"Succession", c'est l'histoire
des membres d'un famille riche
et puissante. Au sein de
la fratrie, tous les coups
sont permis pour prendre la tête
de l'empire médiatique fondé
par le patriarche Logan Roy.
HELEN FARADJI,
critique de cinéma
- C'est des monstres!
Ce sont des monstres, oui, tous.
Il n'y a personne... c'est
ce qui est bien, je crois, de
cette série, c'est que personne
n'est sauvé. Donc, effectivement
c'est une série très noire,
très sombre, mais qui est portée
par un tel talent d'écriture,
un tel talent de jeu aussi.
- La série est une habile
réflexion sur les rapports
de pouvoir dans un monde
de courtisans où les alliances
se font et se défont et où
tout le monde rêve d'être
calife à la place du calife.
NATHALIE PETROWSKI, journaliste
- Ils sont méchants, ils sont
mesquins, ils sont impitoyables,
ils sont prêts à s'entretuer,
toute la famille. C'est toute
une famille! C'est un clan
et je trouve que c'est
très shakespearien.
- "Succession", c'est la misère
des riches, mais c'est aussi
une satire du capitalisme
sauvage dans ce qu'il a
de plus monstrueux.
- Et je pense que ce qu'il veut
démontrer, c'est à quel point
la richesse et le pouvoir
déshumanisent les gens. Ils ne
se rendent plus compte de rien,
ils ne se rendent plus compte
de leurs privilèges, ils ne se
rendent plus compte des gens
qui souffrent autour et c'est
ça, c'est la déshumanisation
de ces gens-là. C'est pas juste
la misère des riches.
Ça va plus loin que ça.
- Maintes fois primée, la série
"Succession" a reçu un accueil
dithyrambique.
- "Succession", pour moi,
c'est une des meilleures séries
du début du 21e siècle.
Mais surtout, je pense
qu'en termes de construction
dramatique, c'est une des
meilleures choses que j'ai vues
même au cinéma depuis très,
très longtemps. Il y a un
travail d'écriture phénoménal!
- La saison 3 reprend exactement
où la précédente nous avait
laissés : Kendal a trahi
son père et la guerre
sera impitoyable.
"Succession" est à découvrir
sur la plateforme CRAVE.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.